number one the pair of numbers you're
searching fortune answer negative five
they should multiply to bigger 24 okay
we've got negative eight and three does
it check out yeah thumbs up do you bet
we do this before if this last one is
negative this last time of the concert
one-half negative 1s be positive because
if both are positive you'll get pot
signs everywhere if both are negative
you'll still get a plus sign here
because they cancel each other out so
look step into are done right it's very
cool point advisor like I meant for you
being one this one here that's a good
question it doesn't matter which way we
put them what is the operation that's in
between the brackets implied but not
written it's multiplication right and
because multiplication at least in the
areas we're working with I don't know
which order you do them in therefore
it's not that big attention okay so if
you did X plus 3 first that's fine as
well X plus 6 X plus one summer first
and last one maybe five and six do they
add up to one yes
today multiply the negative 30 now by
the way I'm just going to tell you a
mental strategy I used to use I
sometimes got confused as to which one
is which which one do I do is that add
and which one multiplies just have a
look at the kinds of questions that you
get
do you notice a fact in this case for
except the last one CD number three five
seven in this case one right what kinds
of numbers multiplied together to give
five seven one answer 105 one and seven
one one
okay that doesn't work you often get
numbers that are prime like five seven
eleven right you get that in the middle
you're not going to find factors for
prime numbers
at least not very often where it is
number yet we get is 24 six thirty
these are numbers that are easy to
factorize right so it's clearly
something times something most likely
went into guru and making those rumors
fantastic well done
now learning to do is to all three of
those questions
I want you to draw a on a line or a
circle and I want you to highlight this
first term okay in this case or in all
those locations it's actually the same
so I want to point out two things you
firstly do you notice in a quadratic
expression you've got terms with are
different powers right this is the power
of two there's a power hiding here as
well what is that power it's one in fact
there's even a power hiding on that
verse number 24 what power is there
there is a power of 1 or the 24 however
actually I didn't say this very few
actually looking at the X's to see that
x squared X to power of 1 this is X to
the power of 0 which is 1 which is why
it's just a number now because the x
squared term is the biggest power it's
important we call it balloons for
meaning that's why you must often see at
the front so sometimes they'll write it
at the back of its negative up do with
that when the leading term has a
coefficient of 1 so now 1 1 1 is just
hiding there if the leading terms
coefficient is 1 we call the quadratic a
monic quadratics M oh and I'm see one
where you see the word 1ik what do you
think that word comes from one mono like
monorail okay or actually call unicycle
but see one owner
ah that's one a but anyway um this me
the kind of quadratic you've got is the
nice simplistic only to get where that
leading term has a coefficient of 1
however as you can see it doesn't take
that much imagination to leave the lead
to have a different coefficient in the 3
is a 4 okay these are monic they don't
get a really fascinating these are just
called
the one Wanek original idea so dealing
with money quadratics is pretty
straightforward you're thinking of this
Carib numbers you've demonstrated really
good at that okay for non-modified it's
a teeny bit more complicated there are
two broad categories which is I've got
two examples that I want to show you
here let's have a look at the first one
not monic that leaving terms a
coefficient script in this case before I
even start to think about it as a
quadratic I noticed that these others 3
9 and 6 share something in common what
do they share they share a factor of 3
which means I can take that out so I'm
going to write equals I'm going to bring
the 3 out the front which means
everything that left is left behind I'm
going to divide by 3 so how many M
squared will I have sighs just one of
them that's how many M Squared they have
how many M's
freeze and what will the company - I
divide 11 that looks good so now you can
see the whole thing is not mourning but
it's big and here years yeah so
therefore I can deal with this guy at a
guy inside the brackets just like I
dealt with any of these one pair of
numbers I look for can squared plus 3 n
plus 2 this is an easy one yep 2 & 1
so with that three at the front this is
just going to be n plus 2 and plus of
one and you're done okay so the first
category of donjuan it quadratic is
really a money quadratic that then
multiply through by a number so you
couldn't treat it much the same way